- So I wanna thank you again
for coming to this event.
To us at MIT.nano, we are
looking to reach across
the boundaries of what you
might have seen before.
Indeed Matthew, when
you mentioned the order
and yet noise down the nanoscale,
that's indeed what the MIT.nano
logo was meant to symbolize.
There is always periodicity that you find
when you look down at the atomic scale,
but you also find a great,
great deal of disorder
in a heights positions, orientations
like those nanowires John
Hart was showing before.
There is that dichotomy
between perfect and imperfect,
and we always have to manage it.
And those scale understandings
will allow us indeed
to take the next steps towards discovery.
So what I want to show you
was the things you can
discover inside MIT.nano.
I'm just gonna spend a few minutes
showing you some images and
reasonings in the way we think
about designing the spaces
that ended up being MIT.nano.
There was a fair bit
of thought and decision
that was purposeful as we
looked at how to make a space,
to make the next set of inventions
and hence take the mantle of what is real,
well it's given to us,
which is redefine what next technology
and what next world will need.
Well, that meant better
understand innovation
and innovation we realized,
comes from very simple, three things.
People who have different perspectives,
hence are from different disciplines,
make sure those people
can meet each other,
and lastly, make sure those
people can engage each other
so that exchanges of ideas
can be fruitful to both.
Ideas then was to generate a space
as central to the MIT campus
as we can get away with.
This is right next to the dome.
It's connected to every other
building in the neighborhood
and extremely easy to reach.
Oh, and make sure no one
feels like the sole owner
of this space.
So make sure no professor
ever has an office
inside MIT.nano.
Indeed, the only offices
you'll find inside
are those of staff members
who run the facility
for the benefit of the entire campus.
Indeed, it was designed with this in mind,
in order to launch the
next set of innovations
we might be able to build.
And so we took pen to
paper and started drawing,
picture emerged of what
piping at least should be.
Well, this is CAD generated.
We did actually design the entire building
down to quarter of an inch
and it was assembled parts of it offsite
and then brought back
in, in order to be able
to be put into what ended up MIT.nano.
The heart of it is clean
spaces down in the basement.
There is imaging spaces that give you
a lot of visualization
capability like never before
on this campus.
And then up on the top
is the ways to launch
those discoveries into prototypes
and hence companies, technologies
that could be given to the world.
We also looked at spaces
around the MIT.nano
realizing that we are
right next to the dome,
we have the responsibility
of telling a story
of what MIT is.
Not just used as facility to
discover the next set of ideas,
hence, we generated a
courtyard through it.
So-called Improbability Walk runs.
Why improbability Walk?
Well, it runs parallel
to the infinite corridor
and there is a staircase at the end
of the Improbability Walk
that connects the two.
I think of it as the staircase
of infinite improbability, right?
But that being said,
there is a real reason why we called it
the Improbability Walk
and that is to commemorate
the improbable journeys
of all of us of actually having
a chance to meet each other
and discover the next set of discoveries
needed to launch forward the world.
That thought really was brought to us
through inspirations like this.
Our friends who unfortunately passed away,
Millie Dresselhaus are renowned scientist,
incredible woman who has
redefined the boundaries
of what could be possible
in the nanoscience.
Has indeed found her journey
to be an incredibly impossibility.
My background is so
improbable that I'd come here
to work from where I started
as a poor kid in the Bronx.
And she particularly
appreciated walking along
with her students who are
younger peers of faculty,
post-docs because she learned
her own way of discovery
by being a young graduate
student University of Chicago
and having happened to have lived
in the same neighborhood as Enrico Fermi.
Hence, taking walks in the morning
with a very famous scientist in the Decaux
all the way to the university,
and in those walks,
she said she learned
how to be a scientist.
She discovered through the interactions,
through the cross-pollination of ideas.
And what does it mean
to take the next step
in the discovery of the world?
Now, as a result, we looked at MIT.nano
and the spaces around it as spaces
that should enable gatherings.
There is the staircase
of infinite improbability
with a singing group on top of it,
because we wanna make sure we use it
as a performing space not just as a space
that is designated for
science and technology.
And the courtyard looked the other way,
on the left is MIT.nano,
on the right are the password buildings
of the original MIT campus.
On the left where MIT.nano
is that whole length,
50 linear feet, pardon
me, a hundred linear feet
on the ground floor and the
floor above are galleries.
Galleries that can
actually provide you art
and provide you ways of
telling stories of connection
of what we do on campus
to the society at large.
The building itself,
you might notice has elements
of design in it as well.
The frit on the windows, I
have been trying to figure out
Kim use it as a binary
code to spell messages.
I'll leave it to you to decipher
if there is a message or not.
I'm sure some of the undergrads
who already gone through
to figure this one out,
but there are views throughout the space
that allow you to see the
space in very different ways.
We have purposely left the windows open
so that those inside can see
the birches on the right,
because seeing the natural
world is an inspiration
for what is happening inside the MIT.nano.
Perfectly clean spaces is
a very comforting thing.
You realize what you're working towards
of you have the world to reflect upon.
Indeed, art spaces like this,
we see as expressions
of artists, builders,
who have indeed thought of
how to reduce the complexity
of what needs to be done inside MIT.nano
into an inspirational moment.
Hence this, these are views
from the windows of MIT
and in the looking into the machinery
that operates the building.
But also throughout the space,
you will find canvases
like the big orange wall
that goes vertically.
That's a canvas five stories tall
that could be painted with years to come
with discovery after discovery
or the next set of ideas
that we might wanna go ahead
and explore or project onto the people.
Indeed, I like to say
that limestone on the left
that is dressing the walls
that (indistinct) the MIT.nano clean room,
that limestone, well, the order for it,
we placed 400 million years ago
because that's when it
was started to be made.
It's a limestone made
of a Louisville deposits
over 400 million years.
I'm sure there are a little
micro and nano organisms
staring back at us from those walls.
We are impressed by the nature itself
and seek inspiration and
hence have dressed MIT.nano
with a lot of natural elements
to allow us to take the next
steps of how to discover.
Now, also we have provided
plentiful gathering spaces
throughout the building
in order to make sure
that you can go ahead and
indeed have that moment
of discovery with someone you encountered.
But also throughout the building,
you're gonna start finding art.
So if you're down on the
first floor on the left,
we show you a piece, we call One.MIT,
I'll tell you about it in a moment,
and then a continuation of that right now
is dressed with a digital
display of 16 TV screens,
running 16 simultaneous videos
from the studio Olafur Eliasson.
This tells stories in a very vivid way
of the way he makes his art
so that when you go and
see the Northwest passage,
the piece of art dressing
in the MIT.nano breezeway,
you can even understand the thinkings
of the artist as he goes forward.
This digital world gallery
allows us to take also
the next steps in energizing the campus
in providing us the next
exhibit and the next exhibit.
And by the way, what
is glowing back at you
are organic molecules
because these are so
called organic LED displays
that operate by using
hundred molecular films.
10 molecules in the middle glow
to give you the colors that you see,
the reds, the greens and the blues,
and the blacks are perfectly deep.
Consequently giving the
largest contrast ratio
between on and off.
Very good looking TVs, just saying.
All right, that being said,
One.MIT as an art piece is
a symbol of the MIT campus.
The quintessential view,
the iconic view of the MIT
is the view of the MIT great dome,
but the MIT great dome is only great
because of who people are
that indeed have walked
through corridors of MIT
to make it as important
as it ended up being today.
So we might as well represented
that way by going ahead
and taking a closer look into the dome
only to realize that the
dome actually consists
of names either bolded or non-bolded
to generate the image you observe.
Now, you might notice that
there is website listed down
on the bottom lower left.
As of today, you can go to
that website, onemit.mit.edu.
And if you wanna find out
where among the 270,000 names
that happen to be the number
of names that compose the image
where your name might be,
'cause you might have been a student,
a professor, a staff,
a visiting scientist,
a Lincoln lab employee,
anyone between 1861 and 2018,
who was in some way associated with MIT
and then found its way
in the MIT directory,
that intellect has been
forever more remembered
in One.MIT art piece.
And indeed what we've
done is taken at five foot
by five foot image and
shrunk it down to a six inch
by six inch silicon wafer etched that way
with all those names.
And they've mounted it
onto the walls of MIT.nano
so that the 270,000 names of all those
who provide intellectual history of MIT
have forevermore been
indeed etched in stone
and memorialized on the walls of MIT.nano.
The smallest line needed
to write the narrow parts
of the letters is four microns.
That's 4,000 nanometers.
From our perspective,
huge, huge dimensions
and the wafer itself has I made at MIT
over in the building 39,
the present Micro-Nano fab.
And it could be in the years
to come remade in MIT.nano
and we will do that in order
to aggregate additional names.
This is another art piece
to see inside the building.
It's has been a gift of the class of 2018,
who worked with us as we developed it.
And professor Craig Carter
led the way in laying out
the wafer and then organizing a team
with a set of people like any wing
from the special projects of MIT.nano,
who indeed organized us
into making this happen.
On the second floor of MIT.nano galleries,
you can see micro mosaics,
an art form that was
perfected about 250 years ago.
What human hand could do
with the art of the time
was essentially take
pieces of glass or sand
that were double the size of a human hair,
human hair width and make an image.
We indeed have a privilege of having some
of those micro mosaic pieces
and we have gone ahead
and zoomed in to take
details of the artistry
and expand them.
So if you walk on the
second floor gallery,
you'll see an expanded views
of little pieces this big
blown to six foot sizes.
Again, in order to be able
to show you the miracle
of what human hand can do with
the tools of 250 years ago.
So just imagine what we'll be able to do
with the tools of MIT.nano.
Now, if you keep on going
on the second floor,
you will see the work of Berenice Abbott.
This is an exhibit of art pieces.
She was a photographer
who happened to have spent
a year with MIT back in 1957-58.
And she would take photographs of cities.
But when she came to MIT,
she realized that opportunity
of capturing science
in ways that have never been done before.
The exhibit was provided
to us by the List Gallery
who made us recognize the
opportunity of juxtaposing
her city work with her science work
and makes I think a very stunning exhibit.
Please check it out.
You can then go to the
third floor of MIT.nano
and actually immerse yourself
in the Spider Canvas exhibit.
It is in the immersion lab
and it's active right now.
You can think of it as
if the described to me
as having a harp with 2,700 strings,
or is it more than that? 270,000 strings?
Every piece of the spiderweb indeed
can generate a different sound,
just like Marcus was telling us.
And as a result, every one of them
can be immersive experience
for you to fly through.
It's then projected on a
beautiful streamed cube,
hence giving a both the visual
and then auditory stimulus.
So MIT.nano is further than dressed
with this final image I'm gonna show you,
which is the Northwest
Passage by Olafur Eliasson.
Today at 6:00 PM, so just
about an hour away from now,
Olafur will give a talk at 32-123,
the Kirsch Auditorium over at Stata.
I believe it's sold out, but who knows?
Maybe they'll let you in, sneak into,
go ahead and actually see his talk.
Say again?
Oh, there was a live stream.
Fantastic.
So you can find it, I'm sure
if you just seek Olafur Eliasson at MIT
and he'll come back.
He's giving a talk to
them in 6 and 7:00 PM,
at 7:00 PM if you're still around campus,
you can please join us at the breezeway.
It's a little chilly. So in the lobby,
in the west lobby of MIT
and Anna will be providing
some hot chocolate I'm told.
And you can go ahead and enjoy
the views from the inside
or from the outside or
the Northwest Passage.
With that, thank you very
much for coming today
and I look forward to seeing
you in the years to come.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)